I want you to imagine getting a phone
call in the middle of the night. Someone
you love has sadly died. In that moment,
how would you expect to feel? Most of us
have an answer ready: devastation,
tears, weeks, maybe months of deep,
unrelenting grief. We expect the world
to stop, for everything to shatter. But
what if the most common response to loss
isn't that at all?
What if for most people the world keeps
turning and they turn with it?
In this video, I want to take you inside
a body of research that has been
building for over three decades. One
that challenges nearly everything our
culture says about how we humans react
to tragedy, loss, and suffering. Let me
explain. At Columbia University, there's
a psychologist named George Bonanno who
has spent his career studying how people
respond to terrible life events. But his
interest in the subject didn't begin in
a lab. It began with his own family.
George grew up in a Sicilian immigrant
neighborhood in Chicago. His father was
a complicated man, hard-working, but
prone to frightening rages.
>> My father would beat us at times. The
beatings were not as bad as the anger
that he exhibited. He would go into
these rages and he was a very scary
human being then.
>> As George watched his father struggle
with depression and feeling that life
was slipping away from him, he felt a
tug of empathy.
He would find his father lying in the
dark and try and talk to him, but his
father would push him away.
When George was 17, he decided to leave
home.
>> My father had said, quite infamously in
my mind, "If you leave now, don't come
crawling back."
>> George traveled widely, sometimes
sleeping outside, drifting through his
early 20s. When he was 23 and living in
Colorado, the past he had been avoiding
caught up with him.
>> The phone rang repeatedly and I was with
somebody. After several repeats of the
this ringing, I decided there was
something very much important. Got up,
answered the phone, and it was my older
brother telling me that my father had
died.
>> George braced himself for the
devastation and mental shattering he was
about to experience, but it never came.
>> What I experienced was essentially
silence.
This silence somehow seemed
um it wasn't what I expected, but it
seemed like
seemed like a natural process.
>> People moved cautiously around George in
the days that followed as if they were
afraid that he was going to splinter
into tiny shards if they said the wrong
thing.
He felt grateful that his father's pain
was over,
but he also felt confused.
He was supposed to feel a certain way
and he didn't. Years later, as George
became a researcher studying grief and
loss, he encountered story after story
of people who didn't follow the expected
script. One was a student he calls
Julia.
>> Julia was home from college. She was
preparing dinner with her mother and the
phone rang and she heard her mother cry
out in anguish and the news was that the
father had been bicycling home from work
and was hit by a car and he was in the
ICU, the intensive care unit. Julia and
her mother drove to the hospital and
just as they arrived, he died.
>> After the shock, Julia returned to
school and threw herself into her work.
When friends asked if she wanted to talk
about her father's death, she said she
didn't. She wanted to be with her
friends, to live her life, not to dwell
on the past.
>> Her mother was quite worried that Julia
seemed to have forgotten her father. She
was acting essentially as if life had
returned to normal and her mother
worried that she had denied her grief.
This was the phrase that Julia used,
that she denied her grief and suggested
that she, Julia, see a grief counselor
to get at the bottom of it.
>> Let's think about that for a moment.
Julia's mother didn't send her to
therapy because grief was destabilizing
her. She felt her daughter wasn't
grieving enough. Isn't that interesting?
And then there was Jed.
An aspiring musician working at an
upscale restaurant in West Greenwich
Village.
One freezing December night, he walked
to a corner and stepped into an
intersection.
>> A garbage truck made an illegal right
turn very fast and clipped him and
pulled him under the truck. It ran over
his left leg and hip and was crushed to
a mass of blood and bone.
>> Jed was conscious through the entire
thing. He remembers hearing them yell,
"Put a rush on the bus." First responder
speak for get the ambulance here fast.
The cold weather slowed his bleeding
enough to save his life. He spent 6
weeks in a medically induced coma,
underwent roughly 20 surgeries, and lost
his entire left leg and part of his hip.
When he woke up, he braced for the
psychological aftermath.
For about a week, vivid memories of the
accident played on a loop.
But then?
>> To his surprise, and I think to maybe
everybody's surprise, it more or less
just stopped. It took about a week and
then that all of these intrusive
memories and intense replaying of the
accident simply just stopped.
>> Jed was confused, not by the suffering,
but by the absence of it.
>> He was wondering, his exact words, "Why
was I doing okay?" And he said, "This is
really my question. Why was I doing
okay?"
>> Years later, Jed became a university
professor.
His question stayed with him. Why was he
doing okay? George, Julia, Jed. Three
people, three very different tragedies,
and the same haunting question.
What is wrong with me?
Why am I not suffering more? Are these
people just outliers, lucky exceptions
to the rule of human fragility, or is it
possible
the rule itself is wrong? Before I show
you what the research says,
I want to try something. I want you to
make a prediction. When a person goes
through a serious loss, what percentage
of people do you think will develop
chronic, long-lasting psychological
damage? What if this serious loss is not
just a personal tragedy, but a
monumental, catastrophic, national
tragedy? 30%? 50%? 80%? Whatever the
number you have in your head, hold it in
your mind for a minute. This was an
exercise that mental health experts went
through shortly after the 9/11 attacks
in New York City.
>> The general consensus really was that
this was going to be a mental health
crisis of unprecedented proportions.
People were basically arguing that there
were simply not enough resources for for
the kind of mental health problems that
were coming. And famously, FEMA, the
Federal Emergency Management Agency,
allocated, I believe about $130 million,
which at the time was a lot more than it
is now,
um for emergency funds in New York,
mostly to provide free therapy for New
Yorkers.
>> I was a reporter at the Washington Post
at the time, and I still remember
sitting on the edge of my bed one
evening a few days after the attacks. I
had spent hour after hour interviewing
family members of people who had lost
loved ones. I had pieced together an
account of all the calls that one man
had made from the burning towers before
he died. As I sat on the bed that day, I
found it hard to breathe. I remember
asking myself if I would ever feel
better. The psychological effects of
9/11 were real, and they were felt not
just in New York City, but across the
country. Early surveys seemed to confirm
the worst. Nearly 8% of Manhattan
residents met the criteria for
post-traumatic stress disorder. For
those near the World Trade Center,
20%. For those directly affected,
possibly 30% or even higher. But as time
went on,
>> the numbers dropped precipitously, and
by 6 months they were more or less back
to normal. They they quite low by 6
months for the for the city of on the
whole.
>> The same pattern repeated itself just a
few years ago with COVID. Experts
predicted a mental health catastrophe of
unprecedented scale, but instead
>> What happened eventually was that the
pandemic did not have nearly the
psychological impact that people thought
it would have. People thought suicides
would would would skyrocket during the
pandemic and in fact suicides stayed the
same or declined globally.
>> In a landmark 2018 study published in
Clinical Psychology Review, researchers
analyzed decades of data on how people
respond to adversity. Across the
studies, they found four distinct
trajectories. The first is chronic
suffering. People who cannot move past
the loss. This is real. It's painful.
And it deserves serious attention and
care, but it characterizes at most about
10% of people. The second was recovery.
People who struggle significantly at
first then gradually get better over a
year or two. The third was a delayed
response. People who barely got by then
slowly worsened. And the fourth pattern,
George calls it the resilience
trajectory.
>> When I first began my career it was
assumed that hardly anybody would show
that pattern. And if they did show that
pattern, there was something wrong with
them. That was the denial idea. When we
began to actually look, we found that
the majority, it's almost always the
majority that's showing that pattern.
Most people experience short-term
distress, upheaval, and then they
continue to function normally after
that. It's not that they don't care.
It's not that they're not saddened or
upset by the by the event, but they move
on with their lives.
>> This finding has now been replicated
over and over again after mass
shootings, spinal cord injuries,
divorce, job loss, financial ruin. The
resilience trajectory is not the
exception. It's the norm.
So let's go back to the number you were
holding in your mind. The percentage of
people you expect to suffer chronically
after a major loss. If your guess was
higher than 10%, you're not alone. Most
people dramatically overestimate how
fragile human beings are. One reason we
do this is because we know how awful it
feels after a tragedy. We know how
painful grief can be, but grief is not a
disorder. As the PTSD researcher
Patricia Resick put it, strong emotions
do not equal psychopathology. Being
upset after a terrible event isn't a
disorder. It's what our stress response
system was designed to do. The mistake
is confusing that initial distress with
lasting damage.
So, if most people are resilient, why
does our culture tell such a different
story?
Part of the answer lies with a theory
you've almost certainly heard of. In the
late 1960s, psychiatrist Elizabeth
Kubler-Ross proposed that people face
death through five stages: denial,
anger, bargaining, depression, and
acceptance. The model was never designed
to describe grief. It was about people
facing their own mortality.
But over the decades, it was adopted
both by professionals and by the public
as a map for how all of us are supposed
to grieve. There's just one problem with
that.
>> It's far too neat and tidy to actually
be true, and the research has never
supported it. There's not been really
been any evidence that that it's
actually what people go through.
>> Mhm.
>> And a lot of research contradicts it.
>> The theory doesn't merely describe
reality,
it prescribes it. If you haven't reached
the stage of depression,
you must be stuck in denial.
If you reach acceptance quickly without
a lot of anger, it must be because you
are bottling something up.
>> The mind and the body don't work that
way. The The grief and emotions are not
dwelling inside us as things.
>> This idea that unprocessed grief is
sitting inside us like a time bomb has
no scientific basis.
and yet it's become one of the most
deeply held beliefs in modern Western
culture. So this raises a critical
question. If the model is wrong,
why does it still exist? George has a
concept he calls the resilience blind
spot. When we are in the middle of
intense distress, we cannot imagine ever
feeling anything different.
>> That initial upset we have tends to
blind us to the idea that we'll ever not
feel that way. We have a hard time as
humans with that. And when there's a
disaster, something large scale, there's
a kind of a contagion that happens as
well. Other people are upset, too. And
so they're upset and I should be upset
and I am upset and now you're upset, you
know, and that's kind of happens
quite fast.
>> Also, therapists who see patients every
day are by definition spending that time
with the people who are struggling. They
rarely see the resilient majority, the
people who never walked through that
door.
>> If they see traumatized people, they see
traumatized people in their practice and
they see a lot more than is in the
normal populations than the base rate.
So they're they tend to then
overgeneralize that to the general
population. It's a very human thing to
do. It's not evil or dumb. It's a it's a
very human thing that therapists do
because they are humans.
>> And then there's social media. It's
become very common for people to go on
TikTok and trauma dump their worst
stories.
There's also an asymmetry in how we
judge predictions. After a mass tragedy,
if an expert warns of a mental health
disaster and she turns out to be wrong,
people shrug and say, "Her heart was in
the right place."
But if experts predict people are going
to be resilient, they might be seen as
heartless.
George has experienced this firsthand.
For nearly 20 years, other researchers
and therapists have dismissed his
findings.
>> Therapists would come up to me if I'd
gave up if given a public lecture and
tell me, you know,
"I'm sure you're a good scientist, but
you're just wrong about this. It's just
wrong. I know and you're wrong."
>> So, we have a model of human fragility
built on a theory that was never
supported by evidence, reinforced by
therapist availability bias, amplified
by social media, and protected by a
cultural taboo against sounding
insensitive. But, does any of this
actually matter? If we overestimate our
fragility, aren't we just airing on the
side of caution? George says no, because
the wrong script has real costs. Think
about trigger warnings, alerts that were
designed to protect people with hidden
traumas from being ambushed by difficult
content.
>> Trigger warnings were born out of the
idea that people have hidden traumas
lurking inside them
or past traumas that were unresolved and
they're kind of somehow raw inside
people. And the research on trigger
warnings has shown fairly convincingly
that they either don't help or they
cause harm. People who are given trigger
warnings often are more anxious than
people who didn't receive them.
>> Researchers have found that the
inability to flexibly adjust your
emotional responses to different
contexts is one of the strongest
predictors of PTSD symptoms. Teaching
people to brace for emotional damage
before they've encountered it may
undermine the very flexibility they need
to cope. There's also the harm of
walking on eggshells. When we assume
that people are fragile, we create an
invisible cage around them. We stop
laughing in their presence. We tiptoe.
We treat them as though they might break
at any moment. But, George's research,
conducted with the psychologist Dacher
Keltner, suggests a very different
picture.
>> Most people, even people who've recently
lost a spouse within the last few
months, when we did interviews, we found
that the majority of people were showing
genuine laughter and smiling during the
interview. You might see somebody crying
and holding their head and, you know,
shaking their head cuz they're so upset,
and then 30 seconds later, they're
laughing. There's still tears on their
face, and they're laughing about
something they remembered.
>> That laughter isn't a sign of denial. It
isn't evidence of heartlessness. It's a
sign of connection with the person
listening
and the person who was lost. Genuine
laughter and smiling during grief are
correlated with better long-term mental
health. It turns out the human heart is
capable of holding grief and joy at the
same time.
To be clear, if you are debilitated by a
tragedy that happened to you a long time
ago, George is not saying it's all in
your head, get over it. Far from it.
There are indeed a group of people who
are unable to function long-term because
of the traumas they have experienced.
They need professional help. They need
our compassion. But believing that
everyone who suffers a setback is going
to be traumatized in this manner does a
disservice to the people who are
actually traumatized. It trivializes a
serious problem. I want to go back to
where all this started, the story of
George. Years after his father's death,
George became a parent himself. As he
navigated the exhausting, beautiful,
terrifying work of raising children, he
found himself longing for a relationship
with his father, a relationship that he
never had. So,
he created one.
>> I began to talk with my father.
Being a father, being a parent is not
easy, and there were times when I just
thought I wish that my father was alive.
Despite the difficulties we had when he
was alive, I felt this would be
different now. I'm a different person.
He would undoubtedly be a different
person as well.
So, I began to talk with my father, and
I found this very comforting to have
these conversations with him.
>> What George was doing was deeply human,
building a relationship with his father
that death, paradoxically, had made
possible. A relationship without the
rages, without the fear, without the
ultimatums. When his children struggled
with money or with the weight of
parenthood, George would tell his father
about it.
>> I would say something, you know, "Dad, I
know you were very concerned about
money. You know, this is really hard."
You know, obviously he never answered
back, but you know, it was more like I
would imagine how he was responding and
just be able to tell him this.
>> This is what resilience looks like. Not
the absence of sadness, not the denial
of loss, but the ability to hold grief
and growth in the same hand. To cry on a
Tuesday and laugh on a Wednesday. To
miss someone terribly
and still build a good life. At the
start of this video, I asked you to
imagine getting a phone call telling you
that someone you love has died. You
probably imagined devastation. And
here's the thing, you might be
devastated
for a while.
You might cry or feel like the world has
lost its color. Those feelings are real
and they are part of what it means to be
alive. But if the science of trauma has
taught us anything, it's this. You are
almost certainly more resilient than you
think you are. The human mind, shaped by
millions of years of evolution, is
extraordinarily well equipped to absorb
shock, process grief, and find its way
back to a life worth living. In fact,
your very existence is a testament. You
are the descendant of a long line of
survivors.
Your ability to get back up after you
are knocked down is literally woven into
your DNA.
The danger isn't that terrible things
will happen to us.
They inevitably will.
The danger lies in carrying around a
script that tells us we're supposed to
be destroyed by tragedy. The trauma
script tells you that you are easily
broken.
The science
says you are not.
If you want to learn more about the
science of the mind and hear about
insights that can change your life,
check out the Hidden Brain audio podcast
on Apple, Spotify, or hiddenbrain.org.
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon.